I was recently learning a new-to-me lace
carriage, and the manual reminded me
of what I consider
to be the worst cast on ever.
I understand that with a lace carriage,
I can't pull needles out
past the B position.
Most of the closed cast on methods that I
use pull the needles out further.
But this sloppy, open cast on is
often taught to new knitters.
No wonder they get discouraged.
Here are the steps.
I'm demonstrating
this on a Silver Reed machine with my lace
carriage, but this method is often
recommended on other
machines with gate pegs.
I have my lace carriage in place
and it's set for plain knitting.
Align all the needles to B position
and then thread up the carriage.
Knit across.
You'll see open loops
across all the needles.
Next, run a strand of ravel cord behind
the gate pegs and in front of the needle
hooks.
The object here is to hold those
loose loops down with the ravel cord.
Hold the tail of the working yarn
and the tails of the ravel cord securely.
Pass the carriage and knit one row.
If all the stitches knit correctly,
continue knitting four or five rows.
Release the knitting
by slipping the ravel cord out.
Immediately, you see a problem when
I hang weights on the edge stitches.
The stitches are not secure.
As a matter of fact, the stitches will
ravel, and because of all those open
stitches, the edge of your
knitting is going to be a mess.
I have never understood why anyone
would recommend or use this method.
Why not simply work a nice closed cast
on with your regular knitting carriage,
and then switch to the lace carriage?
If you don't have more than one cast
on method in your bag of tricks, I suggest
you learn at least two or three
to use for different situations.
But please stay away from this worst
cast on ever.